thanks for joining us at noon and
watching us here at noon i'm bianca
holman deter is reminding folks
resources are available if you're
searching for a job that's after federal
employment benefits put in place during
the pandemic ended for thousands of
nevadans hector mejia is live near
charleston and torrey pines where
there's help free of charge hector
hey there well one stop career center
here right behind me works with dieter
they are funded by federal dollars and
what they do here is they connect job
seekers with employers and they tell me
they've been seeing a steady number an
increase in the number of people that
walk in through their doors asking for
assistance and according to numbers from
the state's department of employment
training and rehabilitation more than a
hundred fifteen thousand nevadans were
receiving the extra federal unemployment
benefits that ended on september fourth
that includes pull-up payments for gig
workers the extra
dollar per week payments also are over
if you are ready to enter the job market
places like one stop career center offer
free help their locations serve as many
as a thousand people a week the one here
at charleston and torrey pines has
computer labs plus workshops for things
like resumes job searching and
interviewing skills they also provide
more in-depth services if you're looking
to learn new skills
and it can be done both virtually and in
person so we want to make sure that we
have that option both just for health
and safety and because you know it's a
job looking for work can be a hard job i
was working by a strip there was i
worked in a compounding pharmacy
and after march 16th that's when
i lost my job and i've been
i've been pennying since then i want to
go out and like you know try to do
something else
the federal boost was a controversial
topic as employers struggled to find
workers moving forward now nevada
switches back to its regular
unemployment insurance and the center is
open from 8 a.m to 5 p.m appointments
are not necessary but you are welcomed
to make one if you would like one-on-one
assistance reporting here charleston and
torrey pines hector mejia 8 news now